I'm Billy Flynn I'm an f-35 test pilot
for Lockheed Martin this airplane is all
about technology what you get to do in
military ation is drive cutting-edge
technologies that you won't ever see in
the commercial world one of most
interesting parts the g-wiz parts of
this airplane I press a single button in
the cockpit and it's transformed into
the short takeoff vertical landing mode
I hover hands on so you can look at this
you see the geometry and you can get a
sense that it doesn't reflect radar
energy but that's not the whole story
we manufacture this airplane so that
every panel every edge every bolt every
nut is covered
that's sophistication that level of
manufacturing does not exist anywhere
else and that allows us to be
essentially invisible to everything on
the ground in the skies on my
helmet-mounted display i see from six
cameras embedded in the skin of the
airplane and I get that fed by cameras
here's two of them one there's one on
the other side there's two on the bottom
of the belly of the airplane there's two
in the top and they build a spherical
image around me and wherever I turn my
head I see as if the structure of the
airplane is not there I base my
experience on more than 33 years of
flying jets more than 20 years as an
experimental test pop it is the most
robust airplane that I've ever been in
it has the most powerful most robust
engine ever developed the 43,000 pounds
of thrust this is an airplane that does
imaginable things already so learning is
like honey we have great confidence in
it